hey 42 here time is an illusion
lunchtime doubly so so what time do you
make it right now probably every person
watching will have a different answer
not just because you watch this video at
different times during the day but also
because we have to deal with different
time zones different clocks and varying
degrees of accuracy but mostly because
you bought that suspicious right liked
what four five dollars in Singapore the
idea of time existed long before clocks
so how do we define it what is time and
what are some of the amazing in strange
ways it can affect our lives early
attitudes towards time were relatively
simple
we used emotions of the Sun to give us
an understanding of our place during the
day Sun high fine food kill food eat
food Sun low find woman go to cave
shouted woman till she make fight there
were also the shifting seasons which we
weren't able to measure but you would
learn to follow them and predict them
from the way that nature changed around
them the first instruments to make time
measurements were sundials but these
were highly localized and from our
perspective as modern clock users the
times will be different each day since
the amount of daylight increases and
decreases steadily throughout the year
by just over two minutes per day in fact
this means at a specific point on the
sundial would actually be reached
slightly earlier or later the following
day there were various other measures
like Sun timers and water clocks but it
wasn't until the early 19th century that
we had reliable mechanical clocks still
they weren't all running at the same
speed but at that point it didn't really
matter
people in every town works to one main
clock and the bells would ring out every
hour on the hour and that's how the day
will be organized then when you went to
a different town you would then work off
that clock which might run at a
different speed but the difference is so
small that you wouldn't notice a change
then came along one significant
technology that made us all realize that
we had to sync up all of these different
clocks and that thing was railways
imagine trying to organize a train
schedule
every stop on the line fix it's a
different time quietly because of their
own town clock being off but also due to
their different positions on the globe a
city like Bristol for example which is
only a couple of hours car journey west
of London would have a solar noon that's
the point when the Sun is at its highest
in the sky about ten minutes later than
London thanks to the 2.5 degree
difference in its position so we needed
a standard or it would all be chaos on
December the 1st 1847 time really began
with the adoption of Greenwich Mean Time
which was often referred to as railway
time until 1880 when it became all of
britain's legal time many clocks would
show both local and GMT on separate
phases the time zones in the u.s. became
vital since the differences over such a
large country were even greater that's
also where the word hello comes from a
telephone greeting needed to be adopted
rather than good morning or good
afternoon since you could be talking to
someone thousands of miles away and
their morning might be your afternoon
Alexander Graham Bell inventor of the
telephone actually preferred the phrase
ahoy-hoy imagine how much more fun the
world would have been if that had stuck
soon each county in Britain had
standardised time and then the world
began to coordinate his communication
and travel became even faster
most countries related their time to GMT
time by 1929 but it wasn't until Nepal
signed up in 1986 that we had a complete
global system okay so that's the basic
history now let's talk about the theory
what exactly is time or at least how can
we define it well time is really three
things or concepts that share a common
name first it is a way to label and
order events in the universe I buy a tub
of ice cream I eat all the ice cream I
feel sick and slightly ashamed of myself
I need something that can show that
buying comes before eating and then
sickness and shame follow it
this is ordering like a calendar
secondly it's a way to measure the
distance between two events the ordering
tells me which comes first but it
doesn't
how far apart they are if I get a new
job and then a new car
will they happen two weeks apart or two
months apart and thirdly and this one is
a little more abstract the time is
immediate we move through that allows us
to see that changes have actually
happened the leaves turn from green to
orange wrinkles grow under your eyes and
that beer belly swells even larger this
gives us the concept of past and the
future it's interesting that the ancient
Greeks saw the future is something that
snuck up unseen behind their backs
whilst the past was laid out in front of
them for them to stare out into sneaky
future you never know what he's up to
this third concept is really important
because it's the only one that requires
us to have an arrow of time a direction
it moves in and never changes the future
cannot come before the present the smoke
never returned from the air into the
cigarette the milk never on squirrels
out of our coffee and I don't reject
that ice cream back into the tub walk
backwards to the shop and exchange it
for money that would be weird and gross
the reason many things seem strange when
you play them backwards is because of
entropy entropy is a second law of
thermodynamics and of all the rules of
physics it's probably the one we are
surest about to put it simply entropy is
the measure of the order or disorder of
the system the law states that the
entropy of a closed system will either
remain constant or increase with time
this means that you will always go from
ordered to disordered think about your
bedroom you tidy it and then it always
slept slowly into a chaotic mess and
saying them as you find a chocolate bar
that is a nice ordered delicious
collection of energy well then you stop
it in your face and that stored colory
energy turns a new kinetic energy for
walking heat and even sound when you
tread on something in the dark and
scream I told you your room is messy at
least now you know it's not your fault
it's just entropy think about a coffee
with milk in it the milk will always
stay mixed throughout the coffee it will
never separate so you have an area in
the cup of just milk and an area of just
coffee if it does then your milk was
really out of date and has evolved into
a sentient being
but why is this well it's really just
probability the amount of ways you can
organize something into a useful or
ordered way is much much smaller than
the ways you can organize it into a
chaotic meaningless mess
let's take writing as an example if you
close your eyes and randomly bash
lettuce on your keyboard for a minute
it's very unlikely that you will make
many words because there are so many
combinations of letters but only a few
combinations make real words take the
word piggy P i GG why there are no other
words in English made from just those
five letters geekbeat you pick a piggy
no one more example put it as keeping a
bowl of water and it will melt and
you'll end up with a bowl full of
slightly more water now if you reverse
time you would expect the ice cube to
form out of the water but how would that
possible how would all of those water
molecules decide between them which of
them had to become the ice and which
would stay as water it just doesn't make
sense
entropy is how we know that time is
destined to move in only one direction
all right so we know that time has a
direction but what about its speed is
time moving at the same rate for
everyone and everything no it isn't it's
relative to the speed you are moving and
by gravity the faster you are moving the
slower you experience time compared to
someone who is not moving this is part
of Einstein's theory of relativity you
can see relativity in action every day
for example if you're on a moving train
and you throw a ball up in the air then
catch it you only witness the ball
moving at the speed you threw it
whereas someone stood on the platform as
the train shoots past them at high speed
watching you throw the ball in the air
through the window will see the ball
move much faster because they will see
it move at the speed you threw the ball
plus the speed of the moving train now
the problem comes when we swap that ball
for a beam of light most of the time the
speed of light is fixed although it can
be slowed down nothing can travel faster
than it so take the same example but
swap the ball for a beam of light the
train is moving can you throw the beam
of light
the air so in this instance the onlooker
would see the beam of light travel at
the speed of light plus the speed of the
Train but that's not possible because
you can't exceed the speed of light so
something must have happened to the time
to make up for the lost speed therefore
in this example you and the onlooker
would be experiencing time passing at a
different rate this is called time
dilation and it's a great excuse of
being played since you can claim that
your watch was just going slower because
you work so fast but in reality the
difference is negligible the astronauts
racing around the earth it's almost 8
km/s in the ISS have aged about 0.005
seconds less than oils back on earth in
the past six months gravity also affects
the flow of time in the same fashion the
stronger the gravity the slower time
passes so if you were stood on a planet
of several hundred times the mass of
Earth for just one hour a whole year
will have passed back here on earth
relativity will never truly have an
impact on our lives until we can build
ships that can move it close to light
speed then you could go off on a trip to
some star and come back to find all of
your relatives long dead and buried and
a bill of fourteen billion pounds
because you forgot to cancel your phone
contract that's the physics side of
things but what about personal
relativity why is it that your current
situation affects how fast that you feel
time is passing you by one hour in a
chemistry class definitely doesn't feel
the same as one hour out in a bar unless
you really love chemistry or you're
rubbish at drinking when you're a kid
summer seems to stretch on forever but
as you grow into adulthood sore is gone
in a blink and you can't remember what
year it is and you realize that you
missed your mom's birthday again and
what about those rare moments of extreme
danger or intensity if you've ever been
in a serious accident you'll remember
that feeling of time slowing almost to a
halt and it seems like you're processing
everything is a far quicker rate than
ever before a neuroscientist called
David Eagleman became fascinated with
idea and with how the brain measures
time your brain is incredibly accurate
when it comes to time it takes sound for
example when you hear a loud bang you
turn your head towards the source of the
sound but how do you know where it's
coming from well that sound comes from
the source and hits each of your ears at
a slightly different time thanks to the
width of your head
which is how far apart your ears are
this time difference is as little as
nine microseconds that's nine millionths
of a second but your subconscious brain
is still able to recognize and use this
information to calculate where the sound
is coming from you also track the
rhythms of the day and night without
needing to see the Sun this is called
our body's circadian rhythm your brain
can even measure seconds minutes and
hours passing by with incredible
accuracy ever woken up at exactly one
minute before your alarm goes off that's
no coincidence your brain is like a
little Swiss watchmakers house stuff for
various timekeeping devices and possibly
some cheese Eagleman tried to test the
effective high-intensity situation the
problem was you can't just go around
pushing people in front of cars or
dropping their pets out of windows to
see how they react so he found something
called a suspended catch her device that
basically involves dropping people
through a hole whilst they face upwards
so that they can't see the safety net
behind them he gave each volunteer a
screen on their wrist which would flash
a random number slightly faster than the
eye can normally see if they did
experience time slower than hopefully
they'd be able to see the number on the
screen suddenly it didn't work but they
did note that when asked how long they
bought the fall had taken volunteers
overestimated by an average of 36%
so something was happening to their
perception of time but this phenomenon
still largely remains a mystery and
finally we can't talk about time without
mentioning time travel traveling to the
future is clearly possible thanks to
special relativity all you need to do is
keep traveling close to the speed of
light and life on Earth will race by
much quicker than your personal
experience of time traveling close to
light speed is no
easy task though it would require
absolutely enormous amounts of energy
and imagine how disappointed you'd be if
you got out of your and still no
one had invented x-ray glasses or a
reverse microwave to make your beer cold
in an instant without those the future
is totally pointless traveling to the
past is a little tricky and we'd almost
certainly need some sort of wormhole to
achieve it but it's at least
theoretically possible having a wormhole
to the past would not define the laws of
physics even if it does lead to the
potential for paradoxes such as the
bootstrap paradox this could be where a
young man travels back in time meets a
girl and gets her pregnant he leaves
because he didn't get into the
time-travel game to get tied down but
the woman gives birth to a boy who ends
up being the time traveller himself he
is without knowing it his own dad he
would make parents evening at school
very confusing so time is many things it
can be a measurement a concept and even
a way of travel we still don't fully
understand the complexities of time and
maybe we never will but in the end it
doesn't matter what it is or how long it
is it's what you do with it that counts
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 he had simply gotten drunk at
a local pub and was walking home past
the palace at 7 a.m. when he decided to
go for a stroll through the halls of
possibly the world's most famous
residence just outside of Munich lies a
sleepy village called fuguro where the
rent for a whole year is just under 1
EUR